[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous on le voit les américains un petit
peu partagés sur cette tentative de
faire sortir entre guillemets donald
trump avant la fin officielle de son
mandat
c'est important selon vous des missions
ou destitution c'est important pour ses
détracteurs que donald trump ne finisse
pas son mandat de manière classique et
lowey certaine façon cela montre que les
démocrates ont du mal à muter une
accusation solide contre donald trump
tout ce qu'ils ont c'est moyen vraiment
obscur et sans doute qu'ils n'auront pas
assez de temps comme on est à terme
cette procédure
voici trois chose qui pourrait arriver
tout d'abord leur tentative échoua et on
devrait échouer mais je pense que elle
avancera un peu car beaucoup des
républicains se sont retournés contre
les mains tremblent cours de la dernière
semaine
cette tentative pourrait réussir et il
pourrait essayer de mettre en oeuvre est
ce cette procédure avant l'inauguration
il ne reste plus beaucoup de temps car
il s'agit d'une procédure à deux parties
tout d'abord les articles de new
richmond
puis le procès devant le sénat et ce
procès qui pourrait déboucher selon le
souhait des démocrates sur une décision
de culpabilité
ils ont commencé
et a essayé de lancer le processus
mais donald entre un peu pour est en
fait arrivé à la fin de son mandat avant
la fin du processus et donc il n'y
aurait plus aucune fondation aucun
fondement légal pour cette procédure car
on ne peut pas destitué un citoyen à
titre civil est donc une solution serait
de parler parler parler essayer de
décider de la culpabilité de donald
trump et a décidé que seul à le rendre
inéligible à l'avenir d'une certaine
manière ce que vous admettez que les
démocrates ce qu'ils font même s'ils
n'obtiennent pas une destitution de
toute façon c'est la fin du mandat de
donald trump mais c'est assez habile
dans la mesure où ils vont obliger les
républicains à se compter entre eux il y
aura les purs les durs ceux qui vont
soutenir jusqu'au bout donald trump et
qui vont peut-être être accusée d'avoir
d'une certaine manière soutenue ces
événements qui se sont passés au
capitole et les autres qui auront dix
n'ont donc c'est assez complexe qui va
se passer en terme de votes
surendettement du capitole il ne
s'agissait que d'un mois une centaine de
personnes sur les milliers de personnes
qui étaient là et je pense que tout le
monde comprend aux états unis que les
démocrates et c'est de prétendre que les
événements horribles ont eu lieu alors
que lorsqu'on jette un regard objectif
sur ce qui s'est passé
n'y avait que quelques forcené a qui
sont contre et il a une quasiment pas de
dégâts et d'ailleurs quand on compare
cela aux manifestations des anti fowl ou
des blacks l'animateur ce qui est arrivé
au capitole
ça n'est vraiment pas sérieux mais il
essaye de grossir cela afin de réduire
l'influencé et le pouvoir de donald
trump mais je pense que le public aux
états unis comprends tout à fait ce
qu'essaye de faire les démocrate nancy
pelosi essaye de causé assez de dégâts
d'un train pour qu'ils ne puissent pas
être à nouveau candidat et encore mieux
essayer de détruire sa réputation
jusqu'à ce qu'il doive quitter
washington en tant que criminel pour
nuire autant que possible à sa base de
soutien
tu n'es pas sa fonction pour trump oui
mais pour les citoyens qui l'ont suivi
vous parlez évidemment comme un coma
défenseur de donald trump et c'est bien
votre droit et c'est pour ça qu'on vous
invite pour entendre votre voix mais il
n'empêche
est ce que ce n'est pas de la trempe lui
même qui s'est tiré une balle dans le
pied avec cette affaire puisqu'il est
quand même vu comme avoir incité à la
violence au capital y compris par de
nombreux républicains n'ont donald trump
n'a pas appelé à la violence le capital
géante
écoutez tout son discours et rien ne
pourrait être interprété de cette façon
s'il n'y a pas ces signaux secret que
les démocrates prétendent entendre de
notre en utiliser les démocrates
demandent à leurs partisans d'être
hostile envers les républicains mais à
donald trump n'a pas tenu ce genre de
discours il n'a pas incité à la violence
et il s'agit encore une fois du bon sens
des électeurs tout ce que les démocrates
font ne va faire que renforcer la base
électorale de donald trump
il renforce son soutien pour 2024 au fur
et à mesure que les démocrates essaye de
le
côté et que cela rend les électeurs de
plus en plus furieux donc je pense que
cela va se retourner contre les
démocrates cela montre à quel point ils
ont peur à quel point ils sont
désespérés
merci beaucoup aux devs perkins est
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france